what I was taught for my boxing stance
is my front foot's forward
the stance is a lot smaller heels up off the floor
but we want to be compact
and we want to be in this position here
so with this karate stance
what's really detrimental again is that front leg
when we're kicking to the leg
in different martial arts
this knee is a massive weak point
against our opponent
it'll take a very simple front kick
to be able to go into this position
the other issue is that I don't really have a
strong rear hand from this position here
or front kicks from this position
it's really be able to design to side kick
those front leg roundhouse
or if I want to spin into my back kicks or spin kicks
this stance really works well right